how are you doing today great how are
you doing excellent um you're someone
who I've admired your work for a very
long time I believe it goes back to
Carlito's Way so I want to definitely
jump back in time do you what do you
remember about making that one because
to me like every time it comes on like
HBO or whatever I'm like hooked yeah
that was my first movie ever and what I
remember was was a kid a kid in a candy
shop I was working with Al Pacino and
Sean Penn and Viggo Mortensen and Brian
De Palma and I was just whenever you saw
me smile in that movie that was real
this is great I would imagine working
with that level of talent has to rub off
a little bit on just the way you present
your the way you work in future gigs
just learning from masters like that
yeah what do you remember what you took
away from that experience that you said
uh I need to be like this in the future
yeah you know the one big I learned a
lot a lot of stuff but the one big thing
that to this day I'll never forget is Al
Pacino's kindness towards me I keep went
out of his way to make sure I was taken
care of and he would run lines with me
he would ask me how I was doing when
things weren't quite working out on set
he would make sure that I was aware of
certain things and that I was protected
and he didn't have to do that he was
like nominated for two Oscars that year
and he was Al Pacino and and and yeah I
mean that was there was one incident
where I was almost
cut out of a scene because I couldn't
keep my eyes closed and they were
blinking from too much caffeine and it
was messing up the shot and so Brian was
gonna kind of just skim over me on to
him and it was my deaf scene it was my
moment and Pacino knew that and and I
have I was I was up for like 23 hours
straight so I was on it's Brussels the
whole time so I was literally shaking
you know I can't stop it and that's what
was causing my eyes to flicker and
DiPalma said okay we'll just go over him
and I'll need it to take a flight to
here to LA that for the eye for the
Academy Awards and it was like you know
an hour before his flight or something
and he was like no I'll just skim over
and we'll just get the shot and he
cleared the room Pacino kept me there
and he said I want everyone out and I
was like about to leave he's like they
say I'm just gonna have an espresso I
just needed everyone out of the room and
I'm like you know the hell am I doing
here then he's like do you wanted an
espresso and I was like yeah yeah sure I
did not want an espresso you know but
you're never gonna turn out Pacino's
espresso so had an espresso with him I
don't know what we talked about but
seemed like hours went by and then he
called everyone back in did the scene
and my eyes didn't flicker and he left
and and yeah I'll that's the lesson I
take away from that movie that's an
amazing story and I say thank you for
sure
seriously it's the first time I said
this movie on camera
I've told friends the story but it took
me like probably ten years to tell that
story to anyone just because I held it
so sure so close to my heart
yep that's phenomenal story like really
thank you for sharing uh jumping into
why I get to talk to you today that was
it that story was the whole thing I gave
you that story right listen I could talk
about my and some of the other movies
for a while yeah let's talk replicas
right so one of the things I like about
one of the things I love about is when
Hollywood takes on like future sci-fi
that doesn't seem so far away yeah
because I look like a hundred years ago
at what the human race was like and the
technology we take for granted now and I
look at this and I'm like it's only a
matter of how many years you know so
could you sort of talk about that aspect
of the story yeah I love that too I love
things that are like oh my god this can
be happening like tomorrow and and
that's what makes it like really scary
and thrilling and kind of fascinating to
me you know because I often wonder what
if we could do this what if we we know
we could do that and you see it you can
see the possibility of those things
happening and with this film that's one
of the things that drew me to it was
that this is like set a little bit in
the future but it's like not too far in
the distance well it's gonna see I don't
even know what I wonder is there's so
much you like for example in the news
recently it came out that like I'm a
Chinese scientist did the CRISPR thing
selected genetically cleared certain
things and it's like it was done without
anyone knowing so I just wonder how
close are we without even realizing that
stuff like this is going on yeah yeah I
mean I mean this stuff on my phone that
I'm amazed at that I can do that with
you know it's just communication like
technology is like you know I mean we
all know this but it's you know it's
changing and advancing so so rapidly you
know that it's like you know whatever we
thought was gonna be in the year 2020 is
here now you know and and so there's so
much that I
our is behind the curtain that we don't
know about that it's gonna be right in
front of our face us dealing with those
things and contending with them or
adapting to them you know how much do we
just stay on our own path how much do we
have to incorporate them into our lives
and how do they affect us you know and
the benefits of that but also the
complications of that I'm very curious
you obviously have played people that do
things and say things you completely
fundamentally disagree with is it super
fun to do that or is it ever
uncomfortable as an actor it's more fun
than being uncomfortable with it because
there is that that that thing of like
this is someone else you know and like
this is not me this is a character you
know in finding like where that finding
the truth and a justification in that
person's brain that doesn't make it up
necessarily so off you know but to
really connect the dots with like oh it
makes perfect sense that that person
would say that or do that because of XYZ
and filling in the x y&z is what I find
really fascinating with what I do I'm a
huge fan of Keanu what is it like
working with him because every I've seen
him on set before he's the nicest guy
yeah he is right you know
so could you sort of talk a little bit
about working with them yeah yeah I mean
I've always admired and respected his
work you know I've always been I love
the matrix and lots of projects he's
done since then and I've heard that that
he's such a nice guy but I wasn't quite
sure of it you know and when you meet
him you get that but you'll forget how
humble he is and how generous he is and
how unassuming he is and how much he
deeply cares about the work you know and
and to me that's what it's all about
when we're working you know and he has
all of that so it was a real thrill and
he's a special dude before I run the
time I want to switch to something else
I'm a big fan of James Gray oh yeah I
didn't know you
ad astra with him yeah I've heard some
interesting things about this project
and James said to me that it was a
daunting before he shot it he said it's
a very daunting script it's a
challenging one what was it like working
on that
god I love James Gray he's the best he's
the best he's just so good
he's amazing and he's like it's like
you're with a friend and you imagined
something when you were six and then
you're like an adult and you're doing it
with that person and a professional
atmosphere but as if you're six you know
and he takes such joy and care with
everything he does and his attention to
detail is amazing he's so kind
super-smart dude constantly pushing the
envelope and it was I mean I just was
like I'll do I'll do anything you know
he called and said you know think about
this I was like I want to think about it
you know he's like yeah but it's small
and what Ellen I don't care I just I
just I just want to work with you you
know so he can ask me to he doesn't need
to write a bigger role for me next time
I'll do this a smaller part completely
last thing for you I haven't seen bumble
bee yet but I bring one to know that has
tells me it's fantastic it is everyone
shockingly right like I'm playing it and
how much fun was it yeah I play I play
doctor of a military doctor in it who's
um who's actually in favor of research
with the robots and and it turned out to
be a really really good movie with a lot
of heart and I think a lot of folks are
going to love it
[Music]